Kym's National Register The Wall Street
Journal editorial page and she joins us
tonight Kim great to see you so before
we get into any of what we've just been
talking about there was news today from
from the administration that the Muller
investigation is reaching its final
stage do you think that's true and what
does that mean exactly
I hope so Tucker because two years of
this is too young two years too long we
need some answers it needs to happen
soon this could be the best thing that
happened to the country in a very long
time if it is indeed finishing up well
that's I mean what a distraction from a
lot of important things that are
happening so if someone who covers the
criminal justice world for a living give
us some perspective late middle-aged guy
no history of violence no passport no
firearms in the home under investigation
for over a year
emails and texts already in the
possession of the prosecutor would you
send dozens of armed men to arrest him
is that normal no of course not of
course not and of course it's not normal
and as you said the standard operating
procedure here would be to call his
lawyer and ask him to surrender and I
think it gets to the other point of your
opening as well to mr. Muller
unfortunately does not answer to anyone
and as a result we can bring up these
topics you can call and ask the question
why did you do it
he doesn't have to answer it and he
doesn't have to answer to anybody in the
end and and that is one of the reasons
that we should hope that all of this is
ending especially when you look at the
list of people he's gone after and the
crimes for which they've been gone after
nearly all of them crimes that he claims
that they have committed after he was
appointed as special counsel not any
four at the time period he was actually
asked to investigate at least not of
Americans so as a constitutional
question how in a Democratic Republic
can you have someone who's accountable
to no elected person who's accountable
to no voters in other words I thought
all power in the government emanates
from voters but Muller stands apart how
can this be constitutionally allowed
well legal scholars have had a lot of
problems with the Special Counsel law
for a long time partly on reasons that
you just mentioned just and also on
accountability questions as well to now
look in theory he can be fired okay but
what we both understand is that
politically he can't be fired because of
the brouhaha that would come up if
anybody were to actually tell him to
step down so why doesn't this can mean
apart from what you think of Trump or
maybe you believe Trump is a secret
agent working for Vladimir Putin but
even if you believe that why wouldn't in
you were too liberal why wouldn't you be
very worried about a prosecutor who was
operating wholly outside the system and
accountable to nobody I mean if you
really cared about democracy that would
that would terrify you wouldn't it well
we've seen the left change their view on
all kinds of things tucker remember this
is a party that at one point cared about
abusive law enforcement tactics they
cared about the things you just
mentioned accountability making sure
that there was accountability in
democracy and that someone had to answer
to someone else but when it comes to
Donald Trump they're quite happy to
throw all of that on the other side and
it has been very frustrating to people
like me who've been trying to write
about mr. Mueller's probe in an
objective way and look at the evidence
out there an objective way and say look
would anybody like to see what happened
to Carter page happened to anybody else
on the basis of these opposition
research that they use the Democrats
should be very worried that a future
Justice Department might do this to one
of their candidates and no one should
want that I will defend that candidate
if it ever happens I mean it I think
this is totally wrong Kim Strauss well
thank you very much for that projective
I appreciate it
thank you